when people refer to social security in
the United States they're really they're
really referring to the OASDI which
stands for old age old age old age
survivors survivors and disability
insurance disability disability
insurance and it is exactly what this
acronym implies it is it provides
retirement benefits when someone retires
or if someone passes away before that
and they had paid into or paid into the
Social Security insurance this Oh a SDI
then and if they pass away it will
provide benefits for their survivors or
if that person doesn't pass away but
becomes disabled and can't work anymore
it'll also provide benefits for them now
one very very common misconception with
Social Security is that is somehow a
form of of a retirement savings account
like a 401k or an IRA it is not that
from the government's point of view they
actually view it more as a kind of
insurance but in reality all it is is a
way of current workers to directly pay
for the retirement of existing retirees
and the reason why they did this is when
it started off in 1935 they wanted the
current retirees to immediately get
benefits they didn't want to wait for
the current generation to save enough
money and only use their money so they
made it a kind of a direct transfer from
the current workers to the people who
are who are using the benefits and just
to make the point clear a traditional
retirement account so let's say that
this is me over my career this is me
over my career and then I retire and
this is me after I retire and so this is
as I get older so this is I'm aging as
we go to the right so while during my
working years in a traditional
retirement plan I would be putting money
into some into some account someplace
and so this would be the case of an IRA
or a 401k and so this is an account an
account someplace and with the cases of
IRAs and 401ks they're tax deferred and
you can invest this and you can get you
can get some you invest it and you can
get some interest on it so it can grow
as you invest it as you put more and
more money into it and you invest it
well and then once you retire that
money that money that you directly
placed there will be used to fund your
retirement that money will you be used
to fund your retirement Social Security
is not this when you pay the FICA tax
and we'll talk about that in more detail
in future videos when you pay that tax
you are actually not putting it into a
little separate account that you will
then tap into later you are actually for
the most part paying current retirement
retirees or survivors or people with
disabilities you're paying their
benefits so the way Social Security
works is more like this you have all of
the current workers paying their FICA
taxes you have all of the current
workers paying their FICA taxes and
right now or at least I think these
numbers are as of 2010 you have 157
million people paying into Social
Security and you have if you have and
you have 54 million people receiving
Social Security and you have 54 million
people receiving Social Security and so
this ratio is pretty good this money is
right now as of 2010 2011 it's enough
money to pay for all of these all of
these benefits and actually we are
running a little bit of a surplus and
that surplus is put into a separate
trust account and it's normally
informally called the Social Security
trust or the more formal name is the
OASDI trust but I'll just call it the
Social Security the Social Security
trust and the idea behind this is okay
look we're running a surplus now we can
cover at least all of our current
obligations and we have a surplus and
then as more baby boomers retire and
more people go from this side of the
equation to this side of the equation
then we can use the trust to kind of
make up any deficits we might have
because as we have more people on the
right we're going to have to have spend
more and we're going to fewer people on
the left so we're going to have less
coming in but look we had all that saved
up surplus before and so we can use that
and that might sound like overall a
decent idea but the problem is is that
this trust is going to start shrinking
is going to start shrinking because of
all the retiring of the baby boomers
start shrinking and we estimate 2023 and
these things move around based on how
much benefits the retirees get the
economy how many people are paying into
it and a whole
all other a bunch of assumptions but
this is we estimate is going to start
shrinking in roughly a decade from now
and the really bad thing is this thing
will be completely depleted this will be
depleted so it won't be able to provide
that extra funding for this kind of this
deficit not having enough money to pay
for all the retirees it will be
completely depleted sometime between
2030 or 2040 and once again this is a
good ways out so it's based on a lot of
assumptions but it's not that far out
this is actually going to affect let's
see I'm right now I'm 35 in 2011 so in
2031 I'll be 55 so I this will
essentially affect my retirement by the
time I retire and I don't know 20
hopefully I'm around 20 40 to 20 you
have to be 67 so I'll have you know what
is that 2045 or whatever I'm going to
retire
based on the current taxes that are
coming in the current level of the
Social Security trust the interest that
the Social Security trust is getting on
its invested money and it's all being
invested in Treasury securities so it's
invested in Treasury so it's not getting
crazy interest it's not you know it's
getting only a few percentage points per
year but it has to because has to be
invested in a very safe place so given
this there are three possible
eventualities either the FICA tax goes
up so based on the number of people
working here you get more revenue per
person right over here eventualities the
benefits go down or even possibly
disappear the benefits go down and
eventualities is by this timeframe right
over here that other parts of the
government's budget I was going to have
to fund Social Security make up the
shortfall because you don't have enough
revenue coming from the FICA tax and you
don't have enough money from the Social
Security trust so other parts other
parts of the budget but as we'll see
there won't really be a lot of other
parts to the budget because you also
have Medicare also growing and actually
Medicare's the really unsustainable one
the one that's growing even faster than
Social Security so this is very much in
question whether there's even another
part of the budget that you could
possibly even take from